what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to geek culture explain and
while we will spend the week running
over all the different trailers and
breakdowns and whatnot that we got from
d23 in this video we are talking about
werewolf by night because i gotta tell
you guys this looks like one of the most
unique projects the marvel cinematic
universe is working on and i absolutely
love it i am so looking forward to it
it's got the black and white classic
horror aesthetic it looks like the
original night of the living dead type
of vibe i'm so looking forward to it i'm
sorry steve i'm so looking forward to it
and i'm really excited to see where it
goes now there was an original synopsis
for the show but there's an updated
synopsis which actually gives us better
detail of what's going on in this show
so the new plot synopsis reads that on a
dark and somber night a secret cabal of
monster hunters emerge from the shadows
and gather at the foreboding bloodstone
temple following the death of their
leader in a strange and macabre memorial
to the leader's life the attendees are
thrust into a mysterious and deadly
competition for a powerful relic a hunt
that will ultimately bring them face to
face with a dangerous monster this
synopsis
gives me vibes on a few different things
the first is that the idea or the role
of ulysses bloodstone is being referred
to as the leader basically what this
looks like is this entire cabal of
monster hunters are led or have
historically been led by ulysses
bloodstone the guy who's in the coffin
and talking to them and say i will be
rotting for you there were theories out
there that it was simon garth which
would have been awesome for those of you
guys who don't know who simon garth is
he's an actual zombie that exists in
marvel comics and goes by the name
zombie but the prevailing theory here
and all indications point to the idea
that it is ulysses stone so if that's
the case then i would argue that the
powerful relic that they're all
basically competing for is the blood gem
of ulysses stone now those guys don't
know what the blood gem is this is an
artifact that does grant people the
normal superhero abilities so like super
strength and speed and durability and
stamina yada yada but it also grants
that person immortality and a healing
factor now one of the things to know is
the powers of the gym are not absolute
that a person is able to use the powers
of the gym relative to how much revenge
they have so if this is a person who is
just hell-bent with some sort of
personal vendetta that seeks out revenge
with just the most extreme passion
imaginable they'll be able to utilize
the gem to its full capacity whereas if
it's a person who's just a little pissed
off because a cop gave them a ticket for
rolling through a stop sign even though
they're pretty sure they stopped they'll
be able to use a decent portion of the
gems power something else that i want to
point out here is that among the
different cast members we saw there are
some that we definitively know for sure
one of whom i think is going to blow
your mind of course there's ulysses
bloodstone who is the guy in the coffin
there's elsa bloodstone who's likely
going to be the one to end up getting
the gym at the end i can't imagine why
that wouldn't be the case of course
we've got jack russell who is werewolf
by night we've got the man thing which
really brings in a whole host of other
questions but there is potentially a
wakandan there and that's one of the
coolest things so in marvel comics there
is a group called the monster hunters
which is actually a group led by ulysses
bloodstone and that's exactly who this
group seems to be if that's the case
there is a guy there who has a lightning
shape cut into the side of his head into
his haircut that reminds me of a
character named zawadi who is actually a
woman in the comics zawadi basically had
a scar across her eye which was done in
a lightning bolt fashion i wouldn't be
surprised if that was the case would
would be really interesting to see that
not everybody who is wakandan actually
stayed with wakanda that some defected
off and one of them became a monster
hunter i think it would just be a really
really cool little thing to have going
on there but we won't definitively know
until the show comes out but as far as
the man thing goes this is one of the
most anticipated aspects of the marvel
cinematic universe that i am really
looking forward to but beyond that it
brings in a litany of questions i mean
the role of jack russell a werewolf by
night seems pretty self-explanatory
given the trailer that we saw that
basically he either snuck into the
mansion or is there in the mansion for
any number of reasons that they're going
to reveal that he's basically a werewolf
and it's going to be up to everybody
there to hunt him right maybe he was
invited there you know we want you to
join our band of monster hunters
psych we're gonna hunt you and then he's
just fleeing for his life but with man
thing and really the tva this raises a
litany of questions and here's the
reason why so in marvel comics man thing
is a guy named theo who at one point was
trying to develop a version of the super
soldier serum he basically took the
serum he memorized it tore up the
documents and then through a series of
circumstances basically ended up jumping
into a swamp after injecting himself
with the serum and because of the
properties of the swamp combined with
the serums properties basically turned
him into the man thing and he's not
nearly as smart as he used to be he's
just a giant lumbering beast that moves
around but he guards the portal to the
nexus of realities so if you were to go
to the florida everglades and if you
were to encounter the man thing and you
were to try to pass him and go into the
nexus of realities the man thing would
test you and he would touch you and
that's where everything shifts because
those who feel fear burn at the touch of
the man thing meaning if you're afraid
of him you will literally burn alive and
you see that happen in the trailer the
man thing grabs a guy's head and then
because that guy is scared of the man
thing he basically burns alive his
entire head just totally fries and so if
you pass the test you can enter into the
nexus of realities and then basically
access the multiverse now that principle
right there would justify the existence
of the tva
but nothing else the trailer does
because the
tva we know from just what we saw in the
loki tv show the time variance authority
exists to grab those individuals who
quote unquote leave their predestined
path and then either take them to the
tva headquarters or just wipe them from
existence entirely and then destroy the
entirety of their timeline and that's
basically it again all of that was done
for the purpose of ensuring that no
alternate realities would lead to the
creation of kang now this gives us even
more questions because we don't
definitively know when this show takes
place it's in black and white so we
could argue that maybe it takes place
back in like the 1950s there really
isn't anything in the trailer to
indicate that it takes place in the
modern era a lot of the artifacts that
we see around the mansion look like
artifacts from the 50s or before maybe
even the 60s potentially but it could
also be that this show is just a giant
roost much like wand division was where
it kicks off with the first couple
episodes in black and white it looks
like a 1950s sitcom and then suddenly
you start fast tracking into the modern
era and you find out that it takes place
in the current age if that's the case
the tva is under the control of king the
conqueror again how the tva is involved
here i don't know because they just look
like guards another possibility here is
that it's not actually the tva it just
looks like the tva there's nothing
that's come out that's verified that it
is the time variance authority they just
kind of happen to look like them which
is not an uncommon thing they've
basically got body armor and they've got
helmets to protect them and they look
like advanced military guys and they've
got staffs they could potentially kill
but are most likely used to subdue
people and like that's basically it but
even in that moment in the trailer when
werewolf by night is facing off against
those agents in that giant room when you
look at the lights they look like lights
from the tva headquarters it looks like
tva stuff so i don't definitively know
what this means and even if you look at
the environment that they're in in the
maze when you have that opening scene
right the scene that establishes the
location the drone shot where it's
overhead it doesn't look like it's in a
giant swamp in florida if anything it
looks like it's out in massachusetts or
possibly on bloodstone island so again
it doesn't look like in the traditional
florida everglades location but say for
example that it's not and say for
example that man thing was taken away
from the florida everglades that means
there's no guardian for the portal to
the nexus of all realities now this is
where we could potentially get into like
the final scene of this show one of the
things to remember here is that we're in
the multiverse saga and so most
everything that the marvel cinematic
universe is producing right now pertains
to the multiverse some things don't
she-hulk for example has nothing to do
with the greater multiverse as a whole
but the thing about this is the man
thing is a character that is irrevocably
intertwined with the multiverse which
means it has to have something to do
with that so what if at the end of this
special right what if since the marvel
cinematic universe always ties into
something bigger when it comes to their
shows for example in she-hulk the
incredible hulk has taken off to sakaar
which is probably going to set the stage
for planet hulk and world war hulk what
if this show
directly segues into loki what if we
look at it like a comic book tie-in and
we say this is going to lead into
something else what if with that portal
having no guards whatsoever
what if loki comes out of it at the end
of the show and that gives us or sets
the stage for the loki season 2 show
which is how loki gets back home and
then his whole event transpires from
there what if that's the case what if
that's what happens we get to the very
end of this show and literally it just
kind of transitions to the florida
everglades and it's like the nexus of
realities or access to the multiverse or
they somehow establish that in the show
itself when they talk about the man
thing and loki steps out and then it
just cuts to black what if that happens
i have no clue having said that i do
love that this trailer has a lot of
mystery it gives us virtually nothing in
terms of how it fits into the bigger
picture of the mcu it could be just
completely and totally isolated the
leaks could be true that it just gives
us the show and the show ends and it has
no involvement with anything else
whatsoever outside of setting the stage
for the legion of monsters with like
werewolf by night and man thing
basically teaming up elsa bloodstone
gets the gym and goes and does her thing
or it could have a much larger role in
terms of tying in to loki or potentially
even something else let me know down in
the comment section what you guys think
and let me know how excited you are
about this show but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end make sure you check out our video
here which has all the highlights from
the announcements from d23 in case there
was anything you missed and i will catch
you all later
peace